nasdaq is looking to move in their
headquarters over here a great segue
because texas attracts businesses
musk is looking to come back here with
bigger projects you know rogan just
moved over here from
california and uh now you've got uh
governor
abbott shout out to governor abbott
low-key guy you know he's not a big
social media guy he's not a big
uh person on social but he welcomes
stock exchanges to austin texas governor
abbott
will on november 200 host
representatives from the u.s major u.s
stock exchanges considering where
whether they will relocate their data
centers from new jersey to the lone star
state
amid the threat of higher taxes love
these higher taxes you know what you
vote for
you lose businesses the coalition to
prevent the taxing of retirement savings
consisting of exchanges operating
and trading platforms including new york
stock exchange owner intercontinental
exchange and nasdaq are exploring their
options
as new jersey governor phil murray
weighs a proposed 0.25
tax per financial transaction per
financial transaction
on firms that process at least 10 000
electronic trades
each year housing data warehouses in
jersey give financial firms in no
advantage other than just being a stone
stone's throw away from wall street yeah
i mean
credits yeah who needs to pay attention
here obviously our good friend mike
tyson slash
andrew cuomo uh phil murphy uh
de blasio our friend cory booker good
friend of the show
um you know test me bro as
uh as we said before you know
they could make a power move and be in
texas in no time i mean you
did this yourself i mean you're a case
example right here yes california was
testing you testing you testing you and
you said you know what enough's enough
can't be there
i gotta move yep tom you know he just
announced that he's gonna be moving
california pretty soon
he's gonna make an announcement
hopefully he stays in the usa i know
there was a concern but i want you to
stay we all want you to stay tom
but at what point do you have to just
say [ __ ] it i'm out
i'm just gonna repeat what i say pretty
much every time on this podcast how are
we become so stupid as a country i mean
there are governors that are just
smarter that are just doing it better
desantis in florida your guy here in
abbott
in texas also keep in mind these two
states don't have state income taxes
and they still have a find a way to make
the state thrive and do well and attract
other businesses
i hope nasdaq moves i was shocked to
learn that new jersey
is the one capitalizing on all the tax
money on these transactions
on wall street are you kidding me did
you know that i mean you think of wall
street you think
you know new york city uh but new jersey
and
so it makes it makes total sense i hope
one of them because it's going to break
the dam
if a big high-profile iconic brand
company institution something like
nasdaq were to actually move to texas
everybody would think it's okay and then
it's gonna then
you're gonna see some real issues for
these states like california
like new york and and especially with a
president
who is in lockstep with these governors
to just do whatever they can
to make your life miserable if you just
want to go about you know
trying to bring back the glory days of
2019 doesn't that seem like a long time
ago now
just to be clear these are the data
centers or data centers
not the actual exchanges so they they
could be anywhere for that matter it's
just
it's where they're housing yeah but yeah
but you got to realize i mean you're you
are making it seem like it's not really
a big deal i'm not
that's not what i'm saying that are
paying a quarter of a percent per
financial transaction
averaging 10 thousand a minimum of ten
thousand electronic trades each year so
this data center is the one that you
want to be over here
you want the data center definitely
you're not going down you're playing
i'm just saying it's not like the the
nasdaq is physically no no no no no but
you're getting your stock exchange isn't
physically made exactly
where the cost is it's what's moving to
texas which is what abbott wants good
for abbot for doing that
i applaud him respect